each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
my name is Kim rickets and I'm here to
introduce and welcome James Elias
who is visiting us as part of the
Microsoft Research visiting speaker
series James is here today to discuss
his new book the amazing story of
quantum mechanics science has met more
demands of science fiction than most
people realize thanks to quantum
mechanics though we don't see the world
of the Jetsons with flying cars people
getting to work by jetpack or Star
Trek's teleporters yet we do have
smartphones pocket-sized computers and
hybrid vehicles because of quantum
mechanics we may also see many more
science-fiction technologies become a
reality
James's professor in the school of
physics and astronomy at the University
of Minnesota he served as a consultant
for the film Watchmen and won a regional
Emmy Award for his role in the science
of Watchmen he is the author of the
critically acclaimed the physics of
superheroes so please join me in
welcoming James with Helios to Microsoft
thank you very much thank you for the
introduction thank you all very much for
inviting me in welcoming me I must say
the working title of my new book
originally was the World of Tomorrow and
so it's kind of a pleasure to come here
and see the guys who actually
responsible for that actually Microsoft
seems to be following me two weeks ago I
was in New York for some media events
and walking around Times Square at night
seeing these huge throngs of people
lined up and what movie or concert are
they going to know they're waiting for
the Kinect to go on sale at midnight so
I assume that you just like give one out
to the speakers but
so I want to talk about the amazing
story of quantum mechanics
my new book first let me give you a
little bit of background how did a
mild-mannered physics professor get
associated with comic book superhero
spider-man and Superman in my day job
I'm a condensed matter experimentalist
so I do basically solid-state physics
I've been doing this for over 20 years
doing research on amorphous
semiconductors you know this is silicon
morphus silicon used in solar cells or
flat panel displays thin film
transistors I've done a lot of work
studying electronic noise in these
materials for about 10 years I studied
sand piles sand was quite hot in physics
there for a while we call the granular
medium when we talked to the funding
agencies and most recently collaborating
with professors in neuroscience using
techniques that I developed a study
electronic noise and disordered
semiconductors and applying them to
voltage fluctuations in the brain but
that's not why I'm here I'm here because
back in 2001 I created a Freshman
Seminar class at the University of
Minnesota called everything I know about
science I learned from reading comic
books which my colleague said explained
a lot this is a real physics class that
covers everything from Isaac Newton to
the transistor but there's not an
inclined plane or pulling insight all
the examples come from superhero comic
books and as much as possible those
cases where the superheroes get their
physics right now obviously you know the
superpowers themselves are impossible
but once you grant a one time miracle
exemption from the laws of nature what
they're shown doing with their powers is
scientifically correct
I showed this cover here because this
was actually a comic that I bought as a
kid even though I wasn't a big fan of
Superman at the time because Superman is
here visiting a college campus and I was
just fascinated to find out what life in
college was going to be like even as a
kid back in the 60s I knew
that this part wasn't too accurate but
there are things here on the cover that
you know as you all know turned out to
be correct
namely all professors at all times
always wear caps and gowns and all
professors are 800 year old white men
but from this class then in May of 2002
I wrote an op-ed that was published in
the Minneapolis star-tribune pointing
out how a key scene in a classic
spider-man comic book turns out to be a
textbook illustration of Newton's laws
of motion I thought well the spider-man
movie is about to open the first one and
so this might be a good opportunity to
get some science into the newspaper the
University of Minnesota put out a little
press release saying well spider-man's
on the big screen but if you want to
know about the science of superheros
person asked is Jim Kelly Asst teaches
his Freshman Seminar blah blah blah I
should point out that they've sent out
press releases about me before about my
work on amorphous semiconductors or one
over F noise result zero you write one
story about spider-man however and the
movie opened on Friday the op-ed
appeared on Friday by Monday I was
getting calls from the BBC the London
Times CNN Headline News The Associated
Press came to my office where I just
happened to have these lecture
demonstration tools on hand that was a
lucky break at this stage of my life I
reconcile myself to the fact that I can
win three Nobel prizes and I know what
photo they're using in my obituary my
colleagues say when three Nobel prizes
like how one Ebanks
this article actually went across the
nation this is a clipping from the
Chicago sun-times it actually went
around the world I think I know what
they're saying about me here in a
Turkish clipping and then I started
showing up in places that physicists
don't usually appear so if you're ever
playing Trivial Pursuit
and you're playing volume six and you
get card 291 I'll tell you right now the
science question the answer is Krypton's
the question is what planet's gravity
did science professor Jim Kirk Elias
estimate by calculating the force needed
to leap over an earth building in a
single bound now I didn't even know
about this one of the graduate students
came to me one day and showed me this
card brought this to my attention I
borrowed the card brought it downstairs
showed it to my department chairman and
I said Alan who's the most famous
scientist you know and he looked at the
card and he looked at me and he said
Stephen Hawking who's not a genius oh
well then the chips and so in 2005 one
of the nice things about all this
attention was the receiving hundreds and
hundreds of emails from students and
teachers and people long out of college
who liked this idea of teaching science
using comic books and asking if I had a
book which eventually led to my writing
a book which is now out in a second
edition and that has led me to the
current talk in the current book talking
about the amazing story of quantum
mechanics that I want to talk about
today because there is a also a comic
book connection uh to this you know
reading comic books they all predicted
what life was going to be like in the
future here's here's an old adventure
comics where Superboy visits goes 1,000
years in the future and meets these
other super-powered teenagers the Legion
of super-heroes and he would this was a
very popular feature Ernie constantly by
being able to break the time barrier
would go a thousand years into the
future and have adventures with the
Legion of super-heroes and in the future
it was promised that we would be in a
better place and the reason we'd be in a
better place is thanks to science in the
thousand years from now if you got in
trouble you wouldn't call for the police
you call for the science police
here in another comic one of the
Legionnaires is falsely accused of
betraying the legion and so they lock
him up and he's got this computerized
device that provides the three
necessities of life food water books but
really this goes back even further
here's from 1928 the first appearance of
Buck Rogers in the science-fiction pulp
magazine amazing stories and they
promised us that in the future we'd have
jetpacks flying cars robot domestic
assistance underwater cities when what
we got instead were cell phones laptop
computers DVDs magnetic resonance
imaging so some guys are reluctant to
give up on the jetpack but we do have
jetpacks right and you can take a
jetpack to work provided you live just a
couple of blocks from where you work
because the problem is it they the
writers of the science fiction pulps and
comic books thought that we'd have a
revolution in energy which is necessary
in order to have like flying cars and
death rays when what we got instead was
a revolution in information and energy
you're pretty much limited to the
chemical bonding strengths between atoms
and molecules and you know for the
physicists in the audience that's on the
order of a few electron volts that's the
energy scale visible like red light has
an energy of about a little under two
electron volts so that gives you the the
sense of the energy what you very few
people in order to have enough energy to
take an extended trip or to levitate a
car you'd need like nuclear power which
produces millions of electron volts per
reactant and but few people are willing
to have an unlicensed nuclear power pack
on their backs
unless you remember the Ghostbusters uh
but they were still it was promised that
we might have you know nuclear power in
our day-to-day lives thought back in the
50s this is the 1957 Ford nucleon the
prototype of a nuclear car I like they
never built it but it would have a
little nuclear fission reactor with a
little mini cooling tower here with tail
fins launch then the car even and the
idea is that you could go five thousand
miles before you'd have to swap out the
nuclear core what you do in the case of
a fender bender was never really talked
about but there's actually an
interesting convergence between the
science fiction future and the real
future that we had Hugo Gernsback first
publishes amazing stories the first pulp
magazine devoted to science fiction in
April 1926 also publishing in 1926 or
when Schrodinger publishing his equation
the short equation which would
serve as the foundation for modern
quantum theory Schrodinger and a handful
of other scientists developed quantum
mechanics because they're trying to
understand how atoms interact with light
a generation later groups of scientists
at Bell Labs and other laboratory
research laboratories developed the
laser and the transistor you don't
accidentally discover a laser you have
to go into the lab and willfully with
malice aforethought go and build such a
device and you can't do it without an
understanding of how atoms and light
interact provided by quantum mechanics a
generation later you get CD players
personal computers laptop cell phones
everything my teenage children would say
without which life is not worth living
none of these are possible without the
transistor and/or the laser neither of
which are possible without quantum
mechanics surely this is pure
well nowadays we would say that this is
curiosity based research right joerger
is just trying to understand how the
world works
Schrodinger Heisenberg Paulie Bohr if
you went to him and said nice equation
Erwin what's it good for
he's not gonna say well if you want to
store music in a compact digital format
but really without the insights provided
by a handful of people the world we live
in would be profoundly different for
example you know we'd still have
computers but they use vacuum tubes so
to have a computer that has the same
power as a laptop it would have to have
be about the size of a room so there'd
be very few of them only corporations
and and the government would own them
there'd be very little reason to link
them together in an Internet there would
be no World Wide Web so there's all
sorts of things that the world has
changed that we don't really think of I
think I once figured out that in an
average hospital there's probably more
transistors than there are stars in the
Milky Way galaxy so we don't notice how
often this comes about so this is all
came about thanks to semiconductor and
solid-state physics which was enabled
due to quantum mechanics how many people
don't know quantum mechanics here great
that'll change by the end of the talk I
have like about 40 minutes to teach you
all quantum mechanics which leaves me
with a problem what am I gonna do with
the other 35 it has a reputation for
being weird and incomprehensible the
ideas are certainly weird but they're no
weirder than saying that we live in a
sea of invisible electromagnetic waves
only a small slice we can actually
detect we never think about that unless
you can't get five bars on your phone or
your laptop and then you notice that the
sea is missing
so let's let me boil it down to
understand how quantum mechanics leads
to something like a laser let me boil it
down to three things like in a comic
book three suspensions of disbelief
three things that you'd have to buy into
that light has both a wave and particle
like property associated with folk term
photons matter has both the particle and
wave-like properties and that everything
light and matter has an intrinsic spin
these are this is all if you if you buy
that that's this is not this has nothing
to do with with you know wave
indeterminancy or the measurement
problem or Schrodinger's cat this is I'm
taking what I describe as a working
man's view of quantum mechanics this is
the stuff that we experimentalists make
use of when designing semiconductor
devices so let's look at the first
principle light is both a wave and
particle like property photons a
manifestation of that is that when you
shine light on a metal if light was just
a continuous series of waves like
washing up on a beach the waves might
eventually push some pebbles up up the
slope of the beach but really what the
light is composed of is a series of is a
machine gun bullet spray and by changing
the frequency of the light the waves
would just the frequency would just be
the spacing between the crests and that
would just determine the rate at which
the pebbles are advanced but the
frequency actually controls the energy
of the bullets and so they increase in
the frequency we can have bullets that
can promote the electrons out of the
material this is called the
photoelectric effect there are of course
practical applications to this that we
all know right that you can get into
photons in this way matter has both a
particle and wave-like properties one of
the most striking examples of this is
interference that's the hallmark of wave
phenomena you have a wave striking a
surface and it gets reflected but maybe
part of it passes through and reflects
off the bottom
if these two waves are in phase they
would add up coherently and we get a
very strong signal but if they come in
out of phase here then they would add up
destructively and cancel out and so when
you look at an oil slick on a wet
driveway the oil slick floats on the
water and creates a free float free
standing film and if it's not too thick
some of the light can be reflected from
the top or pass through and come out
because the oil slick is not a uniform
thickness some regions might have a
thickness such that some colors add up
coherently and we'll see the red light
out of the white light that's striking
the surface whereas the other
wavelengths interfere in turf ear
destructively and cancel and then we
might get a blue light over here and so
on and this interference pattern is a
hallmark of the wave phenomena if I pass
a laser light through a screen I can get
an interference pattern by choosing the
the grid of the screen I can get this
nice circular with dot pattern but if I
send electrons on a crystal electrons
have a wave-like nature that's
associated with their momentum we don't
notice our wave-like aspect because
we're made of lots of atoms so we have
even moving very slowly we have an
enormous momentum compared to an
electron the bigger the momentum the
smaller the wavelength if I walk across
the room the momentum of my matter wave
is a trillion trillionth smaller than
the nucleus of an atom it's impossible
to detect there's no way to see such a
thing for an electron inside an atom its
wavelength is about the size of the atom
it's impossible to ignore
and that's why all this wave-like nature
only became evident when studying the
properties of atoms in detail back in
the 1920s you send you choose the
momentum of the electrons correctly and
they scatter off the atoms in a crystal
and well if the room were darker you
could act
see this a little bit better but you see
the same type of ring pattern with the
spots that I saw this is for laser light
and these are for electrons so you have
the same interference pattern for matter
or light and then the last part is that
everything light and matter has an
intrinsic spin of course those who look
at the old there's those old pulp
magazines know that every month had a
application of spin but I'm actually
more talking about the spin say elec of
a twirling ballerina even that is a bit
of a misnomer it's not as if the
electron were actually rotating like a
top but this is still the the phrase
that's used this rotation is also
associated with a magnetic field that
has both the North and South Pole and we
know in North and South Pole the
magnetic fields flow out of the north
and into the south and so that means
that electrons can have have magnetic
fields that can point in two directions
you can either have a North Pole down
here or it could have a North Pole here
because the charge of the electron is
negative the the magnetic field lines
are drawn in the opposite direction
that's a technicality that we don't have
to worry about but there's basically two
ways to every electron in addition I
mean amass an electric charge has a
little built in magnetic field and that
magnetic field can point up or it can
point down and that's all we need right
so that that took about five minutes
okay so now you're all masters of
quantum mechanics so now we can all over
that magnetism is also very important at
least a lot of practical applications we
know from Dick Tracy comic strips it
will give us flying of flying garbage
cans and I love this this knows the
nation that controls magnetism will
control the universe
but this internal magnetic field that
electrons protons neutrons have actually
enables us to we can do things like we
can store information on hard drives
this way in the
in the movies Ray Milland had to take a
serum in order to as a doctor in order
to diagnose people and see inside their
body now we have magnetic resonance
imaging and that's made possible by
making use of this internal magnetic
field that the nuclei of all atoms have
and so it is impossible without quantum
mechanics if you saw this in a 1930s
movie you'd say no way did someone just
go into this cylinder and the doctor
sees inside them and can diagnose what's
what's you know the what has a tumor and
what isn't right and now it's a standard
diagnostic tool uh oh one of my
colleagues at Professor Bruce hammer at
the University of Minnesota as a favor
used his MRI and did a scan does anyone
recognize what these are hmm yep Reese's
Peanut Butter Cup surprise inside yeah
you could just foolishly bite into it
but thanks to science
right we could we can verify so how do
we combine these three principles to
explain how atoms interact with light
let's use fact first make use of the
second principle that matter has both a
particle and wave-like nature for the
electrons inside the atom that puts
constraints on the possible waves that
can exist we're used to there being
constraints on possible waves think
about a guitar string it's clamped at
both ends so if I pluck it it can
vibrate and I might get this type of a
wave that could be created but I could
not get this wave because it's not
clamped at the end down here it would be
moving so this is not allowed but this
is an allowed wave if I have an electron
that goes around in a circular orbit
around a new
this constraint means that there are
certain waves that fit exactly in and
create nice standing wave patterns and
but there might be other waves that
don't and they're not they can't exist
because it doesn't make any sense to
talk about a wave that doesn't join up
smoothly but since I said that the
wavelength is associated with the
momentum and the momentum is associated
with the energy that means that the
electron can only have certain energy
values inside the atom and so when you
look and then you ask what does that do
in terms of how they atom then interacts
with light now we make use of the fact
that the energy of the light comes in
discrete packets of energy as photons so
when the atom when the electron in the
atom moves from one orbit to another it
emits a photon of energy that has a
color characteristic to that transition
and every atom has its own fingerprint
so that there's a series of of possible
wavelengths that are observed for
hydrogen and a different series for
sodium this also explains by sodium
street lamps have a yellow tinge helium
looks a lot like hydrogen but there's a
line that hydrogen doesn't have helium
was actually discovered by looking at
the spectrum of light emitted from atoms
and thus in the Sun that's why it's
called helium after Helios the Sun God
so it for a long time scientists thought
that maybe this is an element that only
existed in stars until it was discovered
on earth before it was discovered on
earth you know there was no helium the
people didn't know about it so they were
just like drag the deflated balloons on
the Macy's parade a broad way it was
kind of a pointless exercise but anyway
this
nyan has a bit of a red tinge mercury
every element has a unique fingerprint
of different wavelengths and this was
known for at least 30 years prior to
being understood with the introduction
of quantum mechanics this was one of the
the main pushes to understand to develop
quantum mechanics to explain this and
whenever people say well you know some
aspect in biology is too complicated to
actually how you can't you can't explain
it right not being able to explain
something you know is a feature not a
bug it's it's if we understood
everything I'd be out of a job
so this is but it but eventually it was
understood if you want another example
of these line spectra back in the 1950s
you take out as DC Comics strange
adventures where scientist here is
amazed to discover that a spectrogram
plate shows colored lines are caused by
various elements and this line reveals
the presence nearby of a radioactive
metallic element hitherto undiscovered
in the entire solar system I love this
for two reasons
one this is in fact what a line spectra
looks like this is in fact how you would
like the discovery of helium discover a
new element and why doesn't anyone use
hitherto anymore in everyday
conversation and he's thinking it to
himself in complete sentences yeah you
could maybe say that the comic books
back in the 50s we're corrupting kids
minds right because isn't that what
literature supposed to do
but you can't say it wasn't improving
their vocabulary now this picture of
these orbits and the transitions is so
appealing that it's a pity that it's not
right
this was the motivation for Schrodinger
to develop the Schrodinger equation
would because basically if the electrons
weren't orbiting a positively charged
nucleus they
should emit energy continuously in a
continuous spectrum of light and since
light carries energy they should lose
energy slow down and eventually within
actually a trillionth of a second all
electrons should just spiral into the
nucleus that would be a bad thing so to
understand why that doesn't happen char
Nagar basically develop what is it
certainly doesn't look like it but it is
in essence force equals mass times
acceleration for electrons in atoms it
says you tell me the force is acting on
the electron and I'll get this function
here sigh and if I Square sigh it tells
me the probability of finding the
electron at some point in space and time
and what you find is that there's
actually a series of different wave
probability distributions each one has
its own energy and the electron can only
be in one possible wave at a time one
different wave function at a time but
each one has a different energy and you
can then calculate things like what's
the average radius the energy the
angular momentum of these electrons and
the calculated values and the measured
values agree exactly so basically
Schrodinger says that for an electron in
an atom these different possible wave
patterns are analogous to a series of
chairs in an auditorium the positively
charged nucleus is the front of the room
and there's a seat and then at a higher
energy a little bit further back in the
next row there's another seat and then
there's another row that's got three
seats why does it matter
another seat three one five three and so
on and the electron can only sit in the
seats can't stand in the between rows
and so when you have hydrogen say it can
move if I give it some energy you can
move from one row to another and then
emit energy as it moves down you put in
the nature of the forces acting on the
electron with the puck with the
positively charged nucleus the proton
the force is known it's electric
electrostatics and you get exact
agreement with the measured line
spectrum
okay so we understand hydrogen now I
need my third principle in order to
understand something a lot more
complicated like two electrons what
happens if I have two electrons then I
make use of the fact that everything
light and matter has an intrinsic spin
if the electrons in an intrinsic spin
how does that influence when the two
electrons are so close that their waves
overlap like in say helium well the
Pauli exclusion principle states that if
two electrons are in the same quantum
state they have to have opposite spins
basically the magnetic fields have to be
opposite that's the lowest energy
configuration now that's not even the
lowest energy that's the only allowed
configuration anything else cannot have
well anything else the Schrodinger
equation says the probability is zero
not small but zero and if the if the
probability of something happening is
zero it never happens it's forbidden so
I have hydrogen and I want to add
another electron to helium and it could
sit in the front these seats it turns
out or actually love seats okay and
actually kind of like the old curvy kind
so they sit of facing away from each
other but now if I have something more
complicated like three electrons and
lithium it's got to go sit in another
seat because this can either be spin up
or spin down but I then it would be the
same as this one here and that the
probability is zero carbon has six
aluminum has 13 and so now we start to
see why chemistry these arrangement of
the rows come out of the Schrodinger
equation what's the force acting on the
electrons electrostatics it tells me the
arrangement of the seats if I change
this positive charge the spacing between
rows will change slightly which is why
each atom has its own unique spectrum of
light that's given off and then we can
understand why some atoms interact
chemically with other atoms say we could
go back to carbon and these two
electrons and these two electrons
frequently can remix and then if I have
a one of these electrons in one carbon
and another electron with another carbon
atom they can actually form their own
little love seat in a chemical bond and
we have here if they form four chemical
bonds in the same direction we have
diamond I can make use of quantum
mechanics also I just want to show this
you can make use of quantum mechanics to
actually see where the carbon atoms are
by bringing a metal tip very close to an
atom and when it's very near some of the
electrons can actually have a
probability of being in the tip and
being recorded as a current and when
there's no atom there's no electron so
there's no current and so I can use this
to image where the atoms are so this is
carbon again only the stronger form of
carbon this is graphite if you had it
one atom thick you'd have a Nobel Prize
and you'd have graphene and graphene is
extremely strong actually the bonds in
graphite in the plane are stronger than
diamond bonds between the plane they're
extremely weak which is why you can use
it for a pencil you just push the pencil
and you unroll the lay the graphite
layer by layer and it's held onto the
paper by electrostatics which is why you
can erase it easily but you could take
graph you take graphene roll it up into
a carbon nanotube if you had enough of
these tubes that you could braid them
together into a little fiber then if the
fiber is no larger the diameters then
the period at the end of a sentence it
could still hold up to suv's so if you
could make mass produce this in large
quantities
that's your cable for your space
elevator right there I gave you that
idea free Nobel Prize here's a better
image that shows this nice hexagonal
pattern of the carbon atoms here of
course we'd like to eventually get
something a little bit larger than a
single electron to go through a barrier
even if the barrier is just the vacuum
of empty space of course if we ever get
something larger than electrons
we know that comic books will have been
there first here's a nice example from
the 2000 movie x-men look like this one
not that that one oh and they put it
into mute that's too bad oh well that's
a pity
here's here's Kitty Pryde who can adjust
her quantum mechanical tunneling
probability at will and I swear to God
if you go back and watch that scene at
the very end he holds up the textbook
and says physics getting back to physics
let's look at comparing either you know
carbon or or aluminum and let's look at
those last rows and whether the last
rows are completely filled with
electrons or have the seats have only
one electron in them I bring a trillion
trillion atoms together and I form a
solid and they're all chemically bonded
to each other because otherwise it's a
gas so they all are forming chemical
bonds and the question is do all those
seats that then broaden into an
auditorium is every seat in the
auditorium occupied or is it like
aluminum where only there's still a lot
of empty spaces so every seat so every
seat in the auditorium only the half of
them are occupied this is what I call a
metal and this is what I call an
insulator because if I applied an
electric field the here the electrons
want to move they want to gain energy
they get accelerated by the electric
field and there's an ace for them to go
there's a high energy space I shine
light the electron can go up here and
then it drops down or it can go up to
here and drop down it doesn't matter
what what color light I shine I get the
same light back metals are shiny for
that reason
good conductors of electricity and heat
an insulator remember there is lots of
other roads that just didn't have
electrons in them the next row up
broadens into a balcony that's
ordinarily empty I have to provide
energy to push an electron up here now
it can carry electricity remember that
you can only absorb light if there's a
place for you to go so that's why I can
look through a window because the gap
between the last filled state and the
first empty state is in the ultra ultra
violet so the visible light passes right
through so we understand why we can see
through things you add magnesium or
chromium and you could stain the glass
because you put a little seat right in
the middle that some light can be
absorbed by so we understand materials
thanks to quantum mechanics so here
again this showing that if I and if I
actually promote an electron up into the
balcony I leave an empty seat behind and
these empty seats can also carry
electricity because then if an electron
hops into the empty seat I can think of
it as the empty seat moving around so I
can conduct electricity two ways here so
in the next ten minutes I'll tell you
about how lasers work and how that leads
to CDs and blu-rays so armed with this
understanding scientists working very
hard in the late 50s early 60s developed
the laser as soon as it was developed
they held press conferences first
question is this a death ray this is
serious Bell Labs press Department would
brief the scientists don't say death ray
don't mention death ray right good luck
with that first thing in the papers
scientists invent death ray
this is not a death ray this is a death
ray this is an interesting showing how
science closed over to pop culture this
is Ted Maimon and this is the first
laser that he constructed in 1960 four
years later there's a practical
application of lasers in Goldfinger 64
the first lasers built in 1960 that
shows you how primed everyone was to
believe that it was a death ray that it
shows up instantly in going bisecting
double-oh-seven obviously I just I just
learned this a couple of months ago this
obviously was just like you know colored
in on the film but remember in the scene
the the the metal thing is melting
apparently there was a guy underneath it
with a blowtorch it up there I assume
they had like this little with masking
tape this X going past here oh you want
to renegotiate your contract Mr Bond
there you go oh and I want to point out
again this is going back to the old
pre-super hero comic books you know I
know there's competition between
different research labs you know and
there certainly was back back in the
late 50s here's Charles Townes and
Mayman Townes at Bell Labs and Mayman a
huge research lab there was a big race
and a big competition to discover the
laser to build the first laser but you
know the comic books show that sometimes
this competition can be quite nasty in
particular if you're looking at tales of
suspense number 22 it tells about this
giant monster brew - who actually was a
mutated transformed young scientist he
was smaller and skinnier than all the
other fellows and here in college he's
being picked on by bigger fellows but
no he studies he works hard and he
eventually becomes a scientist in a
research lab I think his life is any
better
here he is but even when I was a
scientist working in the laboratory my
skinny frame provided others with
amusement Howard ought to work on
vitamin pills he might discover one
that'll help him grow into a man though
this careful he's liable to hear you
then you'll start another fight and
you'll have to beat him up again so I
don't know what goes on here in
Microsoft but things used to be pretty
tough these this this brew to this this
was out of Marvel Comics before they
started publishing Fantastic Four and
spider-man and they put out a series of
comic books that every month earth was
being attacked by some giant monster
from another planet another dimension
lost in time you have journey into
mystery and I always first-person I
battled rorg king of the spider monsters
hear tales to astonish I challenged
group the monster from Planet X and in
all of these stories the local law
enforcement was useless the military
couldn't stop them Earth was
traditionally saved only by the efforts
of a lone scientist and we see at the
end of the Groot story in particular
here we have the sheriff and he's he
chagrined well I'll be I never even
thought of that
that's why Evans is a scientist and
you're only a sheriff
and I love this here his wife embraces
him
oh darling forgive me I've been such a
fool I'll never complain about you again
never personally I can't tell you how
many times I've heard that from my own
wife primarily because it involves
imaginary numbers but it's a good thing
that scientists were on the case because
it wasn't just roaring and groot every
month brought a challenge whether it was
Lokar or go Moomba rambu groot Oh grog
goog am son of goon has been fang foom
and then one month saw the scariest
monster of all the tax collector from
outer space but back to back to the
laser we have we stake of material that
ordinarily would be an insulator it has
a filled orchestra and a completely
empty balcony and we're gonna add a row
of seats either by adding a chemical
impurities such as some phosphorus out
atom or because it's natural in the the
spectrum of the helium or neon atoms we
add a row of seats right below the
balcony a mezzanine and then we're going
to fill that mezzanine up with electrons
but of course the electrons can only
come from the orchestra that's the only
place that I can bring them so if I
shine light on the material
now the mezzanine the trick is that it's
hard to fill put electrons here but then
that means that it's hard for them to
drop back down so there it's hard to get
in but hard to get out
so I most of the light gets absorbed up
to the balcony some of them fall down
into the mezzanine where they stay for a
while and then even once you've turned
the light off there are still these
electrons in the mezzanine and
eventually they fall down into the open
seats in the orchestra they emit light
when they do and you know what I've
described
here below in the dark toy which I'm
sure there was a point in your life
where this was the greatest
technological achievement in the
universe or you can have so there's
basically only two ways the electrons
can fall down from the mezzanine to the
orchestra they can fall on their own one
at a time like in a glow-in-the-dark toy
or they can be pushed like a laser and a
laser the folk one photon in stimulates
the emission of many photons it
basically causes one to fall which then
triggers the next one and they all start
falling and goes at the speed of light
so you don't see any time delay they all
come down at the same time they all emit
light it is exactly the same energy so
it all has the same color they all do it
at the same time so they're all coherent
all the waves add up coherently you
arrange it so that they all go in one
direction and you get a laser here we
see from a page from dr. solar man of
the atom light amplification of the
stimulated emission of radiation or a
laser birth of a death ray but really
one of the most practical applications
is in storing information on these small
little shiny discs they're actually
quite compact on the disk are a series
of scratches or pits and this is how the
ones and zeros are encoded ladies now
this is an oversimplification of what
goes on inside the CD but it has it has
the basic element of it when a laser
bounces off one of the shiny parts its
deflected to a sensor and that could be
read as that can be interpreted defined
as a zero but if it strikes one of the
edges of the pits it's deflected away
and that's recorded as a 0 a 1 excuse me
so you can encode ones and zeroes from
the spacing of the pits
by changing the color of the light you
can change the wavelength but in the
1980s
you can only mass-produce efficiently
infrared lasers solid-state infrared
lasers the wavelength is quite large so
the the size of the pits has to be big
and the size of the disk was chosen back
in the 80s to be large enough to encode
the information for Beethoven's Ninth
Symphony that was the definition that
was what the engineers set up so that
you could do it all on one disk you
could encode the information for movie
for images and sound but then you needed
a bigger disk and so you had these laser
discs did these 12-inch disks back in
the 80s but by the 90s red light lasers
were the materials issues I mean the
physics was known it's a question of
just the technology which is non-trivial
of course have a smaller wavelength so
now you have can have the the pits
smaller that you can pack them closer
together so now you can have both images
and sound and now we have blue light
lasers which is what the blue and blue
ray stands for and so we can have both
we can have hi-def and so we can replace
ten of these with one of these thanks to
quantum mechanics so I leave you with
this challenge because another aspect
that we were promised aside from the
Dick Tracy comic strips
aside from flying garbage cans was the
two-way wrist TV
Tracy actually was always in the
vanguard of Technology in 1944 the
two-way wrist radio was introduced and
actually if you pop the top on this you
find a series of tiny tubes
which is kind of fair because the
transistor wasn't invented until 47 so
you know you can't blame Chester gold
for not anticipating that you wouldn't
need vacuum tubes just really tiny ones
and then by 1964 at the two-way wrist TV
and this is a bit of a challenge for you
guys here right he's got the the wrist
TV and he also shows all the schematics
here are some of the features of it the
range is not yet been established but we
believe it to be nearly limitless
he's also managed the battery problem
because it uses a powerful atomic bullet
to feed the power I don't know about the
side effects I do know that when he
first put this on this guy had no hair
on his wrist
but this 64 1964 where's the two-way
wrist TV okay but in December of 2008
there was good news there was
announcement that LG was bringing out
the Dick Tracy watch an LCD screen four
lines of data here right so finally we
have beaten Dick Tracy 1986 oh well I
get with a liquid crystal display the
conclusion it's Dick Tracy's world just
living in it
remember the nation that controls
magnetism will control the universe
thank you very much
I just want to point out that both
physics of superheroes and mazing
stories are available for sale and they
have them in the back and so I have one
last slide please concentrate on this
message from the ringmaster of the
circus of crime thank you all very much
and I'd be happy to take any questions
yes sir because it's not actually
strictly speaking true to describe it as
an orbit this solar system picture of a
nucleus that's like the Sun and the
electrons like the planets is actually
not correct it's a useful image to hold
in your head but really what happens is
all you can actually say is that there's
a probability of finding the electron in
some wave pattern and there's a
characteristic energy associated with it
and if you give the electron energy and
if it's an allowed transition it can go
into another wave pattern that has a
different energy and when it goes from
one wave pattern down to another wave
pattern it can emit energy in the form
of a photon but at no point do we
actually know where the electron it
quantum mechanics gives the thing is
just like a perfect theory physics
theory because it gives accurate correct
predictions for anything we can measure
and for anything that we can't measure
it gives nonsense it says like it's like
but I want to know where the electron is
really but you can't measure where it is
really so the answer is shut up
no because if I wanted to measure where
it is really how would I do that right I
want to I want to see where you guys are
really I will find this out by shining
light off of you it will reflect from
your body I will see it in my eye and I
will
where you are but I need to have the
wavelength of the light has to be
smaller than you are okay that's not a
problem but to get the wavelength of the
light smaller than an electron inside
the atom means that I need very small
wavelengths which means very high
energies remember the photons that's now
coming in with a very high energy
electron and it scatters the electron I
can tell you where the electron used to
be but not where it is and that's the
whole notion of the role of the observer
right say you have a vibrating string
and I can't hear it but I've got like
daredevil and I've got super sensitive
touch so I can if you touch the string I
can tell you exactly the frequency of
vibration but of course now I've touched
the string I've changed the vibration so
I can bring myself closer and closer and
I can feel the air vibrating and I can
get a determination of the frequency but
of course the wave is now bouncing off
my fingertips and is interfering with
the the string so the more accurate my
measurement the more I'm disturbing the
system and changing it and so that's the
whole notion of role of the observer and
that type of stuff that enters into it
but at the end of the day we actually
don't for most device work we don't have
to worry about that yes sir try to
introduce Quan Kenny so because of
physics aw for freshmen back in 159
account I probably did are you using any
it didn't work out so well for him but
he didn't have a lot of grants to just
understand instead on a statement of
course and I'm sure you're familiar with
it how do you look at that I mean
there's are different approaches you're
going at it well this is this yes I mean
so Fineman fine mented a in a series of
lectures that are collected in three
volumes the Fineman lectures of physics
he basically reaandtim in' is a real
true genius in you know in the sense
like a a genius like you go into a
darkened room that you've never been
there and he describes where all the
furniture is you turn the light on and
it makes perfect sense what he said but
it you know how would you know it before
the light was turned on
but finding knew these things and the
way he understood physics was very
insightful but not very practical if
you're learning it for the very first
time that was the problem he found you
know after you've already got a degree
in physics reading the fireman lectures
is a great thing to do
oh I could do everything else the 90
degrees rotated what I've done these are
I've been teaching quantum mechanics to
sophomores and undergraduates for many
years and so a lot of these analogies
like auditoriums and stuff like that are
things that I kind of have caught
together over the years but this book is
not meant as a textbook it's meant for a
general readership that would like to
understand say how magnetic resonance
imaging works how does a jump drive work
because I explained how a transistor
works and then once you have that you
can explain floating gate transistors
you can explain jump drives how does the
television remote control work as it is
not meant for scientists and engineers
and I take some shortcuts at some point
I have asked you know a little footnote
saying telling what the correct answer
is and saying if you understood this
this book is not for you it's not meant
for scientists and engineers but rather
for anyone who's going to be a citizen
and a vote
someone because we are all called upon
more and more now to have opinions on
scientific and technological issues
whether its climate change or
alternative energy or nanotechnology and
so I try to couch this in comic books
science fiction pulps because there's a
great deal of insecurity on the part of
non scientists in their ability to
understand this if I describe my
research to one of my colleagues and I
do a crummy job they'll say wait what
and they'll say that again or are you
saying this and they will challenge me
and they will ask questions if I do the
same crummy job explaining my work to my
next-door neighbor he thinks he doesn't
understand it not because I did a bad
job but because he's not quote quote
smart enough and he won't ask questions
he won't interrupt but if you talk about
spider-man or Superman they don't get
the same shields up and if you could tie
it into a narrative like the death of
spider-man's girlfriend Gwen Stacy and
showing how the same physics that
operated their works which explains how
airbags can save your lives in an
automobile crash by tying it into a
narrative people some people have a
better time understanding it so it's not
saying that the way that we
traditionally teach is wrong right they
worked for me but you know there are
other people who are interested in this
stuff and this provides a low barrier
entry point is the idea I just got done
with this one relativity actually there
is in in the expanded second edition of
the physics of superheroes there is
actually a chapter on relativity as it
deals with the flash who obviously has
the ability to run at SuperSpeed so he
deals with relativistic Corrections all
the time
how big is my comic book collection did
my wife put you up to that where's my
wife refers to it the fire hazard yeah
it's a sacrifice that I've made for you
guys you know I read comic books as a
kid I gave it up in high school
upon discovering girls a discovery I'm
not given enough credit for in the
scientific literature that's for another
time
and then in graduate school actually I
was waiting for the results of my
comprehensive qualifying exam and I saw
a spinner rack and saying hey kids
comics and I just picked up a handful
and some were somewhere terrible it
somewhere really good much better than I
remembered
and I just kind of went back into the
hobby I have thousands I don't think of
it as a guilty pleasure because I don't
believe in guilty pleasures right you
like what you like snobbery is the
public face of insecurity so yes
do I ever talk about consciousness
um no the question is do we ever talk
about consciousness and um not
officially I mean it's I work with as
part of my research I work with
neuroscientists and that's obviously the
big enchilada actually is kind of
interesting because one of my colleagues
said that at a neuroscience conference
they were discussing this and they were
unsure of where the breakthrough would
come from whether it would be from
mathematics or physics or electrical
engineering a lot of signal processing
work is being done chemistry and I said
one thing's for sure whoever figures
this out we're gonna call him a
neuroscientist he's in our tribe her
she's an our tribe um
consciousness gets to my very issue of
faith faith at least the way I define it
is belief in something without evidence
because if I could show you the evidence
if I could show you the proof then it's
science or reason it's not I don't have
to believe it on faith my faith is that
everything has a reason that reason can
discern and I can't prove that that's
true because there's a lot of things
that we don't know the reason for you
yet but I believe that they can be
understood one of the things that it I
can conceive it's possible could not be
understood as consciousness because it's
difficult to see say Seattle when you're
standing here in Microsoft right we're
inside the consciousness so it's kind of
hard for us to fully get a handle but I
don't believe it I believe that we will
figure this out that somehow through
these electrochemical interactions will
understand what goes on and
consciousness I'm not 100% sure that it
will have anything deeper to do with
quantum mechanics than simply the fact
that you know it involves atoms but so I
don't I think Penrose is barking up the
wrong tree on that one but that's me
like this one and then the prison that
was it correct to say that that you
don't buy the Copenhagen explanation
mechanic
because I think you know it's kind of
funny the well why don't you explain hey
one thing I learned from reading comic
books you're not a scientist unless you
got it right this is a good experiment
lady person's understanding or the
explanation of bottle caps my
understanding of the coding there's an
explanation of how it is that the
probability is collapsing to why you
can't both determine whether the
electron is involved in one place with
another until you make the observation
maybe the fact that if you can
demonstrate you know experimentally that
this that this electron has to have been
in both places at once before you make
the observation so you know you can you
can prove that experimentally but you
know how you explain it let me let me
take a stab at this because there had
been some experiments on this recently
this gets to this very nation notion of
quantum entanglement that's people are
dealing with trying to develop quantum
computers I said an electron can only
have spin up or spin down right so say I
bring two electrons together and I
arrange it so that the net magnetic
field is zero so one has to be spin up
and one as it's been down but they're so
close together electrons are called
fermions because they obey Fermi direct
statistics but electrons all look alike
okay that's not the prejudice statement
of an anti-fur might but it really is
true that they're indistinguishable so
it doesn't matter which one is on the
left and which one's the right so I
don't know which one is up in which one
is down but I get them so close that
they're now entangled now I bring along
I stretch my infinitely stretchy ribbon
and I bring them across to two ends of
the country and no one breathes no one
disturbs them because the stretchier it
gets the easier would be to break the
ribbon once the ribbon is broken
what's done on one end has no
communication with the other now it's
not the fact that once I measure and see
that this one is up I instantly know the
other ones down because that's just
logic right I knew that the total had to
be zero the thing is I pulled a fast one
on you through the whole talk up or down
compared to what we're in a room so we
think of up and down this way but it has
a magnetic field and it's up and down
relative to the magnetic field that I
put on if my magnetic fields pointing
this way this is going to be the
up-and-down direction if the magnetic
field is pointing this way this will be
the up-and-down direction that's the
information that gets transferred
because it's not just that one is
pointing in one direction and the other
is in the other but once I do the
measurement it then creates a direction
and that information is instantly
transformed transformed transferred
transferred to the other end of the
ribbon because it's basically the same
wave pattern it's just the same ribbon
so that get that's the part that
Einstein called the spooky action at a
distance that he and because it opens up
the possibility of faster-than-light
communication because it's the same wave
and so what I do to one suddenly and
that's where these collapsing wave
functions and all of this stuff comes in
the really disturbing part experiments
seem to show that that's right I
recently further there's this nice book
out on quantum entanglement Zeilinger I
butchering his name I apologize but by
the guy who actually does life is being
yeah but um this is a popular book on
quantum entanglement that just came out
after you buy my book you can buy that
but but that that gets but that's in
these issues but it's been only recently
that we've been able to experimentally
probe this so up until then it's been in
the realm of more philosophy once you
start interacting with the outside world
and you jiggle you break the ribbon then
measuring one end doesn't do anything to
the other end
that's called decoherence that's the
world that we live in that's why I don't
believe this
coherence entanglement has anything to
do with consciousness because your brain
is at 98.6 degrees Fahrenheit the atoms
are jiggling so much that any coherent
wave pattern gets destroyed there was a
in the back
could you speak up please so sort of
said waiting off of consciousness I know
why I did
but what if the patient's does that have
on the discussion free well
well has a question I don't there's a
lot I I'm just like a humble guy in the
lab making putting I'm happy if I can
get nanoparticles in my semiconductor
because the NSF has a rule that every
grant proposal has to have Nano in the
title sure I can I can answer questions
as long as people want but there was
someone back there and then I'll get to
you in the blue sweater well you did you
have a question enabled students online
yes and no yes I mean base yes um I'm
really I'm set with myself for not
remembering exactly how to pronounce
this guy's name is I linger the guy who
wrote this book that I just mentioned
has entangled pairs of photons sent them
through fiber-optic cables so that
they're the equivalent of 17 miles apart
measure the polarization of one at one
end and it determines the direction of
polarization of the other oh no no it's
it's absolutely the only thing that's
getting teleported is information that's
exactly right
it's info but it is it's real
information right I mean in terms of
that we know that it's circularly
polarized and the other circularly
polarized in the other direction but it
relative to what axis is not determined
until you do the measurement and then
the other one gets instantaneously
determined but that's information
information though it's not just logic
it's not just saying spin up or spin
down it's like the electrons that case
it up or down relative to what yes sir
so when they did that how did they
actually change it
they prepare the states in different
ways they pass it they can pass it
through magnetic fields that rotate the
polarization there's there's a lot of
clever experiments I'm not an expert on
all of that that I can tell you up
Austin's on my head but they they there
are ways of actually getting at that you
can flip one and the other one a well
not only that but again the point is if
I if I measure it and find that this
electron is is pointing this way because
this is the magnetic field that I put it
on then the other one is pointing in the
same direction that's not trivial right
because I could have done it if I did it
this way then it would be them this way
there's no they're physically they're
spatially separated once you've measured
then they're not entangled oh absolutely
yes that's that is correct well no no
you want you measured one that
determines what the other one is doing
yes yes no it's not information no I
think it is information because I can
say I could set I could set a binary
code magnetic field this way is a one
magnetic field this way is a zero and so
I could then transfer a one or a zero
across the country whether it's faster
than the speed of light or not experts
disagree but I can transfer information
one or zero
well yeah you the process of doing that
collapses all the different because it
has an infinite possibility of which
direction it points in as soon as I do
the measurement it's now pointing in
what the direction I measured but so is
the other one even though I I can come
back the next day and measure it and
find that it's still pointing in that
direction that's the thing by graphene
yeah so really for the layman
we are reading these news about in all
over Brazil I think I think the news is
just that he was eating something that
came or something some materials you
manipulate all this layer it's got the
table something exactly yes with one
layer of the atom does your book it
talks a little bit about graphite I
think the graphene I think the graphene
was a little bit of a premature Nobel
Prize but this is this is coming from a
little bit of sour grapes I thought for
sure this was gonna be my year
I gave 50 bucks to every member of the
committee keynote to the chairman told
my wife we'd better go to sleep early
we're gonna get that 2:00 a.m. wake-up
call money down the rat hole anyway
the idea is that you have carbon wants
to form four chemical bonds right in
diamond it forms four equally strong
chemical bonds in a tetrahedron of age
arrangement if you look at at these
atoms each one the average number of
neighbors and closest neighbors is three
so it's got three very strong chemical
bonds but there's a layer above it and a
layer below which means that it's got
like in essence half a bond above and
half a bond below so in the plane very
strong bonds out of the plane very weak
bonds so yes you can peel it with scotch
tape and you peel and you take the piece
that you had and then you peel it again
and you peel it again you're appealing
you're peeling the material off layer by
layer when you just write with a pencil
and here you're just using scotch tape
and you're just cleaving the crystal and
you keep doing this until you get lucky
and you can get a layer very small
that's only one atom thick now that's
not what's so cool about graphene what's
cool about graphene is that those oh
that oh the
three electrons that are in the bond I
don't care about them they're bonded up
that one electron that's now not
attached to anything all of those
electrons are sitting up standing up out
of the plane like like posts in a field
and all of those can overlap and for a
very technical reason they act the
electrons in this broadened out one seat
band move as if they were like
relativistic massless particles the
equation that describes it is the
relativistic version of the Schrodinger
equation and called the Dirac equation
and also depending on how it overlaps if
you look in one direction it would look
like a metal in another direction it
looks like an insulator it's got all
sorts of cool electronic properties that
you know get get into the weeds though
and are much more advanced well the idea
is that the electrons yes that if they
move as if they were like massless
relativistic particles that they move
very fast so you'd have very fast
transistors since this is so strong and
98% of the light passes through it it'd
be great for making an invisible force
field because you couldn't see it the
light would pass through it and you oh
there's graphene there I'm sure all
right but you take you peel it apart if
you if you wrote very lightly you might
actually be able to get a little layer
of graphene with your pencil